હ
[Musique]
he
aux quatre coins du monde des cargots
gigantesque sillonn les océans pour
ravitailler les lieux les plus
[Musique]
reculés au Canada sur la basse côte nord
du Québec Le Bé des gagners dessert des
villages perdus dans la
[Musique]
nature en Polynésie française le nucuo
parcourt les archipeles d'î enatoo pour
approvisionner des populations isolées
de
[Musique]
tout deux histoires de bateau
d'existence lointaine et de survie grâce
aux voix que trace la
[Musique]
mer
au cœur de l'océan Pacifique un archipel
magnifique la Polynésie
française plus d'une centaine d'îles
éparpillé sur une surface grande comme
[Musique]
l'Europe Tahiti l'île principale située
dans l'archipel de la société abrite un
des plus grands peuples de navigateurs
du
monde les cargot partent de cet endroit
on les appelle ici les goellettes en
souvenir des anciens bateaux à voile qui
depuis papette ravitaillaient des îles
les plus reculé de
Polynésie tous les mois depuis 20 ans le
nucuo fait le tour des toitoutou et des
Gambiers des archipel à plus de 2 jours
en bateau de
papette
ce matin le cargot se prépare pour son
dernier voyage de l'année Alani est
l'homme clé du nuco il est en charge de
la
marchandise non ici il y a que que la
rou que la rou celui-là Makemo que les
deux contenai
là la porte
ici et nous on s'occupe de tout ce qui
est réception des frettes et les
chargement des conttainurs làdedans il y
a un peu de tout il y a des congélateurs
après il y a la bouffe tout ce qui est
fragile on met en haut et tout ce qui
est lourd
c'est ça que on met sur
palette le bas quoi en fait c'est notre
dernier voyage il faut qu'on qu'on gagne
le maximum de de place vous serez chargé
à rabord
ça c'est
[Musique]
sûr
au petit matin le nucuo quitte papette
avec ses cales plein de marchandises
neuf marins à bord et même quelques
passagers en 3 semaines le cargot va
ravitailler une vingtaine d'î
[Musique]
et pour mener le navire à tous ses ports
il y a le commandant William
Smith on a un bon temps un bon temps
c'est pas c'est pas tous les voyages
comme ça c'est pas t les le voyage là on
a une belle calme pas de pluie ah c'est
agréable j'ai commencé ici en
1996 c'est un des Vau suis resté le plus
longtemps ça fait 21 an maintenant j'ai
toujours aimé les
to je suis pas fait pour ê pour être
dans le
bureau ah
oui
[Musique]
le cargot arrive sur ao un banc de sable
on dirait le
Paradis a est une île coralienne avec
son lagon de plus de 600 km car c'est le
plus grand des Moutou c'est aussi le
plus peuplé 1000 personnes vivent ici en
permanence en cette fin d'année le
cargot est attendu avec impatience par
les
habitants dans ces cont de quoi tenir un
mois entier et passer de bonnes fêtes de
Noël chacun vient retirer ses
commandes
sans bateau on peut plus rien faire
quoi on dépend des bateaux
aussi David est le marin en charge de la
distribution sur le
quai madame super
merci on est tout le temps de gauche à
droite et il faut pas s'énerver parce
que des fois les clients il s'énervent à
attend attend il faut quand on quitte
l'île on a tout déchargé il y a rien qui
[Musique]
manque et pour ceux qui ont raté les
commandes il y a toujours la petite
échope ambulante d'alani un petit
container transformé en épicerie
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
alors sera un G un gasoil un sac
d'oignon un sac d'oignon un sac de pomme
de
terre avec de
bonbon ok ça te
fait
fr voilà merci Merci à VOUS bonne jourée
vous aussi
dis-moi tu as des fruits non tu as pas
de fruit non tu s à quoi à
transporter tout ce qui est
marchandise uniquement pour les magasins
comment je
vaire besoin de fr mais tu pries le
Seigneur c'est pr le
seigneurou il y a pas les fruits que je
veux quoi il y a que des pommes j'ai
besoin d'orange des pommes j'ai besoin
d'autres fruits quoi il y a pas enfin je
vais attendre le prochain bateau je peux
rien
faire c'est pas toujours simple
d'habiter sur Anatole ah ben c'est
plutôt
[Musique]
compliqué
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout juste au nord du 50e parallèle sur
la côte nord québécoise se trouve la
ville des SEP îles c'est de cet ancien
poste de traite de fourrure français que
nous montons à bord du B des
gagners un bateau unique qui
approvisionne en très peu de temps une
dizaine de villages isolés sur plus de
km il sert de moyen de transport aux
7500 résidents de cette région du bout
du monde c'est un cargo
mixte il est près d'unhure du matin on
est au printemps mais dans cette région
du Nord c'est encore
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'hiver la B des gagn se prépare pour un
long trajet allerretour en un peu moins
d'une semaine
l'équipage espère qu'il n'y aura pas de
tempête de neige pour retarder les
opérations des résidents de la côte nord
monte à bord ainsi que des passagers
pour qui le rêve des grands espaces
canadiens prend tout son sens plusieurs
conteneurs sont à charger des véhicules
toutes sortes de matériel et de la
nourriture c'est Martin Pinot gérant de
terminal qui supervise les opérations
sur le qu les conteneurs sont blanc en
fait eux sont à température contrôlé
donc c'est le verable tout ce qui est la
nourriture donc
j'ai réfrigérer congelé aussi du
chauffé de SAV à linge à 40
ça j'ai aussi des beaucoup de matériel
pour la pêche à ce temp la pêche reprend
le 12 avril cette année à blan outils
l'essence
j'ai entendu parler de la possibilité
dans les semaines à venir peut-être de
chère c'est les limit pratiquement de
l'imaginaire plutô les limite du navire
mais on peut voir avec la grosseur du
nav les limites sont quand même assez
grandes en fait je suis en train de
procéder à l'inspection du véhicule
c'est surtout de voir si dommage
apparent sur la carrosserie en fait pour
éviter les réclamations pour en même
temps s'assurer on prend bien soin des
véhicules de nos
passagers pour ce soir j'en ai seulement
quatre et on a déjà eu jusqu'à 20
véhicules dans certains
[Musique]
B après 1 heure et dem de chargement Le
Bé des gagners prend la mer pour une
traversée de nuit qui le mènera à
portmenier sur l'île d'Anticosti un
paradis perdu au milieu du golfe
Saint-Laurent
[Musique]
oui maintenant jusqu' en ce momentl j'ai
V de palais et j'espère qu'on va
[Musique]
voir je m'appelle Kathy je suis de la
Suisse mais j'habite à
[Musique]
30 près de 7h après avoir quitté le port
de C
Anticosti est en vue une île immense qui
compte plus de chevreuil que
[Musique]
d'hommes
regarde Eric et Marie profitent du
bateau cargot pour se faire livrer de la
marchandise des produits essentiels mais
également des petites
gâie c'est la sorte qu'on aime en plus
qu'est-ce que c'est des réglisses c'est
la première fois je savais même pas qu'
en faisait des
rouges pas ça ici non on a pas ça ici on
est limité aux patates légumes C
d'ner on est les personnes qui demurent
le plus loin là de toutes les résidents
ça va prendre quoi 5 minutes là à C
vitesse là à peu près là ici à l' ce qui
est drôle c'est que autant que c'est
c'est vaste là tu sais c'est plus grand
que Montréal Québec c'est plus grand que
l'île du princoir c'est pratiquement la
grossseire de la Jamaïque puis tu as des
des kilomètres des kilomètres de route
de sentier puis quand la neige vient ben
tu tombes à peu près à 8 km sais de de
route d'
[Musique]
neiger ça c'est mousse la visite au he
oui est Arru par bateau mais dans le
ventre de sa mère
ouais ça c'est Lui Il a 2
ans Eric et Marie ne pourrai pas
totalement se passer des arrivages du
bateau mais ils tiennent par-dessus tout
à préserver leur manière de vivre on a
avoir un bateau qui nous charie de la
salade au magasin que ce soit ça tu
auras jamais la fraîcheur que tu as sur
place c'est ça qui nous a charmer un peu
de de venir s'établir ici pour notre
autosuffisance les premières années
onait pas d'animaux passait peut-être 18
chevreuil pu c'était notre viande pour
laanée on mangeait juste ça on on avait
pas d'autre viande que du
[Musique]
chevreuil alors que éic et Marie restent
dans leur petit coin de paradis
l'équipage du B des gagnés poursuit ses
opération une véritable course contre la
montre avec 20 escales en 5 jours le
navire ne doit prendre aucun retard
c'est à corédevau premier officier sur
le bateau un francophone de la Nouvelle
Écosse que revient la tâche de
superviser les opérations de chargement
et des
chargement donc
iciess de faire dans 2 he dem mais c'est
s de respecter l'oraire plus possible
pour Don service au
passag
[Musique]
opération cargo réussie dans les temps
cette fois la météo a été
clémente mais il y a souvent des
tempêtes de neige et les bzards peuvent
souffler sur la région 5 mois par an le
bé des gagnés reprend sa navigation sur
le golfe Saint-Laurent vers la route
nord du Québec où s'effectuent toutes
les autres
livraisons direction le port de
Saint-Pierre Jonathan Marcotte 3è
officier sur Le Bé des gagners supervise
la navigation on est présentement
AutoPilote donc pas personne à la roue
le navire s'en va tout seul en suivant
son cap on est peut-être à peu près une
dizaine de mil de la côte au sud de la
côte les navires les PES conteneur il se
risquent pas si près de la côte il y a
que nous là qui est assez temééraire
pour pour circuler près de la côte comm
ça les autres bateaux de marchandises
passent par le détroit de HDO au sud
d'Anticosti plutôt que le D3 JAC
quartier où navigue Le Bé des
gagers c'est plus rapide pour se rendre
aux ports les plus importants du golf
Saint-Laurent le chenal est plus profond
là aucun risque de tomber sur un
iceberg au contraire tout près de la
côte les vents les haut fonds et les
rochers exigent que le capitaine ait une
grande expérience
surt lorsque la neige rend la visibilité
quasi
nulle ce n'est qu'après avoir accosté
que son bateau est bien aré et que tous
les passagers sont arrivés à bonort que
le capitaine Philipp peut relâcher la
pression si on considère qu' c'est 1852
m quand on est à point 01 on est à
18,50 de la roche donc c'est des
conditions qui ne permettent pas d'être
déconcentré qui permett de se divertir à
d'autres affaires qu'à celle de la
navigation chaque port nécessite une
connaissance précise des lieux et pour
rentrer dans tous les ports que nous
desservons on a besoin d'avoir un faible
tir en dos pour pouvoir rentrer à
maréute comme un Baré bass
[Musique]
la PL des choses ici c'est des par de la
nourriture pour la
aussi un peu de matériel de construction
c'est aussi i que je pren tout notre
propane la plart de la
propane encore une fois les opérations
cargo ont été rondement menées Le Bé des
gagier a respter son horaire il met le
cap sur d'autres villages encore plus
isolés vers des TER des sauvag le bateau
devient encore plus essentiel car aucune
autre route ne peut y
mener retour sur le cargo des îles du
Pacifique le nucuo a déjà parcouru près
de 1000 km depuis son départ de papette
il y a une
semaine
en 7 jours de mer le bateau a déjà
ravitaillé une dizaine
d'Atol l'étape de ce matin le petit Atol
de nego est un peu
[Musique]
particulière AR la
Nord
on va se mettre à la dérive le temps que
ils vont charger les de baliniens de là
ils vont repartir vers le village c'est
lo c'est loin le village il faut en gros
1 he 1 he de
binière on peut pas accéder non
non qu'un seulun
seul sont déjà partis aujourd'hui al
livre des bidons d'essence et de la
nourriture
pour convoyer la précieuse marchandise
les marins empreinte une baleignière une
grosse barque à moteur qui permet de
ravitailler les îles inaccessibles au
[Musique]
Cargo
nego est un petit banc de sable posé sur
la
mer il forme un immense lagon où la
navigation est
difficile les corau affleur à la surface
de
[Musique]
l'eau
on a même pas
d'alignement tellement le lagon est
rempli de de cailloux quand on rendre de
la passe on fixe directement l' qui est
là-bas là on peut pas aller en haut à
cause des
[Musique]
cailloux
fallit aller en
haut là on est bien dans un caillou une
grosse
patate c'est des choses qui
[Musique]
arriv ok ça y est en
Rep fois ça passe mais des fois ça
coince negogo est l'un des rares atols
polynésiens à appartenir à un
propriétaire
privé on y trouve qu'une simple piste
d'avion et aucun
habitant à part ce couple de gardiens
ils vivent 6 mois par an sur
negono
oui merciche
[Musique]
le jeune couple est en charge de veiller
à l'entretien de lî une vis partiate
loin de toute contrainte de la vie en
communauté
la vie ici c'est trop cal on est
vraiment coup du
monde il y a pas des choses qui te
manquent la famille de temps en temps on
essaie de les contacter mais le reste
non j'aime bien cette vie là
elle est bien comment comment il faut
dire c'est agréable à vivre quoi tout
est là tu manques de rien la nourriture
tout tout est là je préfère être que
nous deux que plusieurs personnes parce
que c'est à cause aussi des regards des
gens préfère être tout seul comme ça
j'aurais pas plus de problème B vous
êtes un peu ador oui oui mais dommage
les sont pas normalement ils sont
déshabillés mais là ils sont
[Rires]
[Musique]
habillés
le prochain passage du nucuo sur negono
est prévu dans 2
[Musique]
mois sur le cargot les marins ont pris
l'habitude de poser des lignes de
pêche et parfois les prises sont de
taille
cette fois-ci c'est un espadon de
presque 2
[Musique]
m
manger là faut être plusur dessus
ah oui ah il y a que des gros mangeurs
là je sa pas souvent qu'on
pason pas
ça
voilà oh mais là c'est petit on part à
5 voilà par que celui-là il est petit
voilà ouais c'est petit ça petit
uti le troiste est le plus vieux marin à
bord c'est son dernier voyage sur le
nucuo avant sa
retraite comme là maintenant j'ai
travaillé pendant 29
ans tout le temps à la
main mais les gens éé il cro c'est çale
non et tu restes au soleil dans le
soleil dans la pluie tout matin jusqu'au
soir c'est dur c'est sur le soleil la
tête
aussi
Joseph lui aussi est l'un des matelots
essentiels à la bonne marche du cargo
c'est le cuisinier poulet au lait de
coco ben je fais le menu de la semaine
ben des fois on nous emmène du
poisson poisson des îles ben voilà fait
mieux manger le poisson que la viande la
viande le poulet m donné comme là les
copains ils ont pêché ben c'est
magnifiqueist la bien préparée
[Musique]
là tuux plus à que
que c'est ton foyer ça elle est marée
elle est cuisiné c'est très important
que il y a une tout ça parce que
voilà manger pourx ils sont contents de
bien manger ça faut faire avec amour tu
vois tout en amour si tu aimes ce
métier tu fais avec amour pas de
[Musique]
secret une autre journée de travail se
termine pour les matelots du nucuo dès
demain à l'aube ils sont attendus sur un
autre Atol un autre bout du monde du
Pacifique
[Musique]
après une nuit de navigation et quelques
transbordements Le Bé des gagné accoste
à
[Musique]
Kegaska à partir d'ici et jusqu'à
l'extrême est du Québec il n'y a plus
aucune route
[Musique]
praticable comme à chaque arrê le prier
offercrbi de temps le bateau restera à
qu pour informer les passagers qui
souhaitent aller se dégourdir les jambes
sur la terre ferme c'est la p ici oui
c'est la p juste si ch à prendre puis on
s'en va après
ça sans Le Bé des gagners il serait bien
difficile pour les résidents de la basse
côte nord de continuer à vivre dans ce
pays grandiose mais isolé surtout quand
on ne peut pas prendre la route blanche
Caroline vit à la romaine encore plus à
l'est elle préfère emprunter le bateau
pour sortir de son
village la route blanche où qu'on voyage
en M on fait au P de c'est tu V jusqu'à
blblanc
donc de chez nous de la Romaine si je je
les
festival de la romain jusqu'à Kasco
[Musique]
focus Pho
camin
nu
notre
père je vous salue
Marie Rach
estenne elle revient d'un séjour d'une
semaine à cette à plus de 450 km de chez
elle
elle est allé rendre visite à son frère
atteint d'un cancer qui se fait traiter
en ville c'est pour lui qu'elle prie le
B des gagn est vital pour elle et pour
sa
communauté mais ça représente amener les
marchandises des fruits frais des
légumes
pu les
VoyaG quelquun qui a enfs il peut pas
voyager en puis en chalope
pendant que le bateau vogue vers sa
prochaine destination Coré lui est à son
bureau gérer le transport de dizaines de
tonnes de marchandises exige une
planification complexe et irréprochable
pour que les 120 conteneurs ne bougent
pas trop durant la traversée et que le
cargo lui-même reste
stable ça c'est le devant du bateau en
fin de compte le devant du bateau donc
chaque
és
ave numé cont
destination je juste d'ajuster
po enyé photo du du camion que
j' camion de
ton avec
uneuse à prend
BL maxum pour la Gru c'est 40 ton pour
le poids de la grue mais le maximum de
tonnes c'est environ entre 600 650
tonnes on va mettre un peu de couleur
dans notre vie mais quand on est en haut
de saison un maximum qu'on peut servir
là on a 381 passagers à nourrir plus 50
m
d'équipage je
pas il est 13h je suis en pause jusqu'à
20h ce soir donc j'attends après mon
lavage je prends un petit café ouais je
commence à avoir pain j'ai manqu le
déjeuner puis manqu le dîner donc
commence à avoir
[Musique]
pain oh merde on amen c'est
bon oh
[Musique]
salut
le monde se promène un quat rou ouis ici
ça un voyage dirais qu'il y a un quat
rou deux à chaque maison là ouais dans
le village mais c'est pas trop contrôlé
fait que on peut rouler tant qu'on
[Musique]
veut le B des gagners repart direction
Harington Harbor un endroit magnifique
mais difficile
[Musique]
d'accès dans le Pacifique le nucuo
continue sa tourner des
[Musique]
atols ce matin il atteint varatea un
anneau de sable d'à peine 3 km²r posé
sur l'océan
50 habitants peuplent ce bout du
monde toutes les terres émergées sont
couvertes de cocotiers leurs noix sont
la seule richesse de l'archipel des toit
[Musique]
Moutou pour atteindre la tole
les marins doivent laisser le cargot au
large ce matin la houle est forte et
l'approche est
[Musique]
difficile les marins du nucuo ont aussi
un autre rôle fondamental ils collectent
le copra la noix de cocos séché cultivée
par les habitants de la
tole ça c'est du cprat de première
qualité
alors donc c'est la chair de la noix de
coco qu'on récupère pour qu'on on envoie
l'huileerie pour qu'il se soit
transformé en huile huile vierge d'huile
de cpra donc alors le kilo il pèse 140
francs le kilo de première qualité et
deè qualité dans les toit Moutou il
coûte 55 francs voilà c'est grâce à ça
qu' c'est la seule ressource qu'on a au
tooto cette habitante de varatea profite
du bateau pour envoyer des cadeaux de
Noël à sa
familleprié al ça ce sont des poissons
qu'on envoie sur papété pour les et la
famille pour qu'il puisse manger ce qui
est frais pour les fêtes et tout eh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attend ils sont courageux ces matelot
hein ouais ils sont très courageux comme
vous avez vu ce matin quand vous êtes
rentrés dans dans la passe il y avait la
houle hein pas dangereuse c'estriuse
encore plus
P là je vais récupérer mes glacières qui
sont arrivé là ben justement je remercie
le bateau comme ça on a de quoi manger
pour la Noël et les jours de fête
surtout on est des îles éloignées tu
vois on n pas de piste d'avion on a rien
du tout donc on a on a besoin de des des
goellettes pour nous ravitailler c'est
un service que Don on a toujours besoin
quoi attends c'est ça
sur la
plage est
aaiss il P les récolteurs depr en argent
liquide de l'argent le PER d'acheter de
prière
nécessité de TR à la
polynési il est complet
celui-là c'est le grand carrefour
de Mar c'est un sac de riz un sac de
pain deux viandes et un shampoing merci
[Musique]
Mar de son côté David s'occupe de
distribuer la marchandise commandée il y
a un mois un sac de
riz et un sac de
[Musique]
suc tu es mon
frère dès qu'il voit le bateau ils sont
contents ils ont besoin de nous et nous
aussi on a besoin d'eux parce que dès
qu'on arrive on amène un peu de
[Musique]
joie
le NUC repart chargé de copra il met le
cap sur l'un des Atol les plus isolés de
l'archipel
[Musique]
desou retour sur la bas côte nord
québécoise au
Canada Le Bé des gagés poursuit son
itinéraire vers le nord la traversée est
de plus en plus périeuse pour continuer
sa route le cargo va peut-être devoir
faire appel à un briseglace de la Garde
côtière canadienne pour l'heure le cargo
mixte arrive à Harington Harbor un
pittoresque village de pêcheurs qui
compte 260 habitants mais accoster dans
cet endroit n'est pas toujours facile le
part de Harington Harbor la roche passe
vraiment très très très très près
donc il y a des réf
immergés c'est pas une cte hospitalière
au niveau de la navigation si je peux
dire un Nair conventionnel entendrait
des bonnes conditions météo pour entrer
à Coster
ok nous on peut pas se permettre ça pas
avec le r qu'on a avec 21 port dans une
semaine donc beau temps mauvais temps
vent pas vent neige pas neige il faut
qu'on
progresse
les touristes arrivent sur l'île et ils
n'en reviennent
pas absolument fantastique c'est
incroyable vraiment j'ai jamais vu comme
ça c'est tellement impressionnant c'est
isolé et les gens qui vivent ici c'est
tellement j'ai jamais vu ça je suis pas
habitueux de ça
OK
écoute moi j'ai pensé que c'est une rêie
que c'est c'est comp une rêve
[Musique]
vraiment Le Bé des gagier quitte ce
village enchanteur à la tombée du
[Musique]
jour
pour l'instant tout va bien et le bateau
progresse en heure l'équipage se prépare
maintenant à accoster dans le port de
Saint-Augustin à l'embouchure d'une
rivière la mer est recouverte de
morceaux de glace les marins doivent
évaluer s'ils auront besoin
d'aide donc ça c'est notre carte de
glace ça n donne l'information sur les
glaces dans le golf à avoir besoin de
l'assistance des brises glace pour les
jours à
venir c'est une rivière donc c'est de
l'eau douce de l'eau douce ça gèle plus
rapidement que de l'eau salée c'est le
premier po on avoir besoin d'un brise
glace et au printemps c'est un des
derniers port où on avir besoin d'un
brise
glace je vérifie voir si j'urais pas des
échos sur mon radar qui indiquerait la
présence de iceberg qui est peut-être un
peu peu probable à ce temps-ci de
l'année mais surtout là de de glace en
provenance du
[Musique]
Labrador aux premières lueurs du matin
le brise gllace de la ctière canadienne
est à l'embouchure de la rivière qui
mène au port de
Saint-Augustin après plusieurs heures à
évaluer la situation les capitaines des
deux bateaux conviennent que le B des
gagers peut commencer son approche seul
vers
saintaugustin le chemin d' glacé a été
ouvert par le bateau de la Garde côtière
il y a quelques jours la couche qui
s'est reformée est assez mince elle
n'empêche pas le cargo d'entamer sa
navigation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
2.7 cette fois encore les transbordeurs
ont réussi à manœuvrer le cargo malgré
la
glace Le Bé des gagné met maintenant le
cap sur blanc Sablon mais la présence de
glace l'a retardé
le 3è officier Jonathan Marcotte tente
de regagner le temps
[Musique]
perdu je c'est Jo ça va
ouais on va prendre les quatre moteurs
[Musique]
salut après 7 he de navigation Le bateau
cargo mixte arrive au bout de sa route à
blanc Sablon une sorte de bout du monde
où parfois les ourses polaires viennent
saluer les000
villageois ici l'opération cargo est un
peu plus compliqué car il y a plusieurs
containur et de camions à
transborder
[Musique]
avant merci le capitaine philippear a à
peine le temps de souffler pendant le
transbordement qu'il doit déjà penser au
retour de nouveau 2000 km à parcourir
dans cette nature sauvage où la neige
ici se faitine 7 mois par an fait
demi-tour on va refaire tous les ports
qu'on a qu'on a dervi à l'allé on va les
redervir au retour pour nous permettre
de récupérer les conteneurs vides qu'on
a laissé en place et pour délivrer en
fait toute la marchandise qu'on a
embarqué ici parce blanon également P de
chargement
[Musique]
je penseon ne se lasse pas de de tel
paysage parce que c'est ça le bonheur de
la mer comme de bien des endroits dans
la nature c'est changeant et donc on on
a jamais
exactement les mêmes conditions les
mêmes la même luminosité mais la lumière
de la bascôte est
[Musique]
remarquable
le soleil se lève sur le
[Musique]
Pacifique le nucuo continue sa tourner
des îles
isolées
ma première maison ça ah
oui toujours sur la route
voilà et tous les mois c'est comme ça
c'est la
[Musique]
routine le cargo transporte des vivres
mais aussi quelques
passagers ce matin revient chez lui à
tour de retrouver ma femme et mes
enfants ça fait presque 3 mois je l'ai
plus vu elle a très impatient de les
retrouver mais je reviens avec des
cartons plein
quoi quelques
cadeaux de la
nourriture je veux juste voir les yeux
briller des enfants tu vois quand il
voit un truc content tout ça là tu vois
dans les
yeux et ça ça fait chaud au cœur
[Musique]
ouais tourya est l'un des atols les plus
reculés de l'archipel des tout
[Musique]
Moutou cadeau pour les
enfants
[Musique]
ça c'est un peu
L
[Musique]
une autre passagère est restée elle sur
le cargo pour mari-louise la tournée du
nucuo prend des aires de voyage
initiatique durant toute ma vie je me
suis toujours occupée de ma petite
famille mais là cette fois-ci je me suis
dit qu'est-ce que ça fait de de voir et
de sentir ce que les autres font bon à
la maison n'est pas tellement d'accord
parce que je voyage seul j'ai dit non il
faut que je le fasse oui mais tu sais
même pas qu'est-ce qui va t'arriver
qu'ils sont les gens à B j'ai dit il
faut que je le fasse et j'étais
déterminé à le faire et voilà je me suis
embarqué sur le
bateau
mais je suis sur le
[Musique]
Bau après une journée entière de mer le
cargot atteint l'île de
Mangareva c'est la fin du voyage dans
lestoit Moutou les Atol ont disparu ils
ont laissé la place aux îles haute c'est
le début de l'archipel des
[Musique]
Gambiers
me reste
encore 12 î à faire je
P tout le monde dis que les atols se
ressemblent mais pour moi non il y a
quelque chose de magique dans chaque
Atol parce que chaque Atol a son
histoire et je pense que je n'oublierai
jamais ce voyage c'est mon voyage à
moi
[Musique]
à partir d'ici le nucuo va remettre le
cap sur papette il mettra plus d'une
semaine pour revenir à son port
d'attache avant de repartir encore à
ravitailler les îles lointaines du
[Musique]
Pacifique